on passe maintenant de chez la semaine
avec des 24es c'est geoffroy le jeune de
la l'heure actuelle que nous retrouvons
sur ce plateau après le magnéto désintox
de ce soir la lutte contre neige
[Musique]
les attentats du 13 novembre ont mis
tout le monde d'accord la france est en
guerre c'est ce qu'elle dit notre
président la guerre c'est ce qu'a répété
son premier ministre nous sommes en
guerre et comme sarkozy n'avait rien à
dire de plus 20 il a rajouté un à perdre
il faut le faire dr bref nous sommes en
2015 et tout le monde est d'accord avec
ce que disait charles pasqua il y à
presque 30 ans entre les terroristes et
nous à bière la guerre est engagée
pasqua voulait terroriser les
terroristes
trente ans plus tard on voit le résultat
[Applaudissements]
pourtant tout le monde allait retrouver
que c'est une bonne idée de se lancer
dans une guerre contre hadès
[Musique]
ah la la le problème c'est qu'en france
on a toujours eu entre 10 et 20 ans de
retard sur ce qui se faisait aux states
en l'occurrence on a 14 ans de retard
sur le discours de bush au congrès après
l'attentât du world trade center
stop
handfield
résultat après avoir détruit totalement
l'irak pour se venger d'une septembre
nos amis les américains se sont rendus
compte que ben laden se plante et
finalement au pakistan il qu'on finit
par le but et obama en a profité pour
faire une belle photo sauf que pendant
ce temps la dèche s'installait en irak
et en syrie aujourd'hui les états unis
et la russie bombardent des juges sans
relâche
mais comment faire pour lutter contre
les djihadistes qui vivent en europe
faut-il aussi les bombarder au lieu de
bombarder jaca la france devrait
bombardé molenbeek jaca on syrie
molenbeek en belgique d'où sont venus
les commandos du vendredi 13 depuis les
attentats tous les discours se
durcissent hollande s'est rallié à ce
que proposait sarkozy en 2012 déchoir de
leur nationalité française les
binationaux condamnés pour terrorisme
nous devons pouvoir déchoir de sa
nationalité française
un individu condamné pour actes
terroristes mais l'opposition réclame
déjà plus et laurent wauquiez voudrait
qu'on enferme toutes les personnes
soupçonnées d'islamisme déchéance de
nationalité pour les binationaux mais
aussi et c'est le centre du problème
centres de rétention pour ceux qui sont
nés français sans prendre aujourd'hui le
risque d'attendre mais est ce que c'est
vraiment une bonne idée d'en fermer
ensemble tout ce qu'on soupçonne de
djihadisme pas sûr en irak les
américains avaient enfermé tous les
djihadistes en prison pour mieux les
contrôler résultat c'est dans les
prisons américaines en irak que s'est
créé l'organisation de l'état islamique
voilà c'était désintox signé blaco mise
en image de julien grappes qui était au
bataclan vendredi soir et qui s'en est
sorti je ferai le jeune bon choix remet
ça
il ya très dérangeant politique à
valeurs actuelles
bienvenue parmi nous dounia bouzar vous
êtes anthropologue et directrice du
centre de prévention
contre les dérives sectaires liées à
l'islam vous avez publié
désamorcer l'islam radical comment
sortir de l'emprise djihadiste et la vie
après death alors vous expliquer en fait
une chose très étonnant c'est que le
défaut d'intégration ou les perspectives
professionnelles ne sont pas forcément
les causes de l'enrôlement dans le
djihadisme on a des enfants de
professeurs des enfants d'avocats des
enfants médecins 3 % des filles
von roll dont le jihad sont issus de
familles juives c'est très étonnant
c'est ce qu'on appelle la mutation du
discours jihadistes c'est à dire que
pendant dix ans était toujours la même
raison pour combattre ça s'adressait
plutôt à des jeunes que on appelle son
père ni repère fragiles socialement
fragiles familialement et puis là depuis
deux ans on voit que des jeunes comme ça
épanouie premier de la classe peuvent
s'arrêter peuvent se faire embrigader et
la question c'est pourquoi alors vous
expliquer les argumentaires des
recruteurs de dèche l'an d'abord il ya
le mythe de mère teresa ça c'est pour
les filles on leur dit vous avez sauvé
des enfants qui sont gazés par bachar al
assad sont des filles qui voulaient
faire infirmières médecins aides
sociales qui déjà été altruiste et dans
des familles humaniste et finalement les
rabatteurs arrive à retourner ses
valeurs humanistes contre elle or pour
les garçons c'est le mythe de lancelot
dites vous alors ils veulent devenir des
soldats se battent contre bachar al
assad
et c'est la raison finalement de
s'engager oui le énormément de garçons
ont pas supporté le fait que finalement
on interviennent pas quand bachar
el-assad et gaz et son peuple l'année
dernière et finalement les rabatteurs et
said leur tenait ce rôle en disant tu
peux pas rester là à ne rien faire à
être qu'inutile il faut au moins en fait
à les remplacer l'intervention
internationale voilà alors vous dites
c'est une secte
totalitaire qui ressemble au nazisme et
c'est vrai que pour les nazis tous ceux
qui ne pensaient pas comme eux étaient
des choses et finalement quand ils nous
tirent dessus
vivent pas comme des personnes mais
comme des choses ça c'est la fin de
l'embrigadement c'est à dire que la
dernière étape de l'embrigadement
c'est effectivement de passer de l'envi
de sauver le monde à l'idée que tous
ceux qui sont pas à leur place tous ceux
qui ne pensent pas comme eux tous ceux
qui sont pas engagés dans ce groupe là
sont des gens qui sont complices avec la
dégénération de l'ensemble des sociétés
et du coup ils passent de l' envie de
sauver à l'idée que s'ils veulent sauver
il faut exterminer tous ceux qui sont
pas engagés avec eux y compris les
autres musulmans il faut bien insister
c'est pas une guerre de civilisation
les premiers à être mort c'est les
musulmans syriens qui sont les pauvres
sont parqués dans des tentes et les
riches sont arrivés mais il ne faut pas
oublier que tous ceux qui ne font pas
allégeance sont exterminés alors vous
guillaume non je voulais demander à
dounia c'est parce qu'il ya deux trois
jours dans le monde y avait un grand
article sur est ce que tout ça est une
pathologie ou pas de l'islam ce que veut
dahesh c'est que l'ensemble de la
planète pensent que c'est une guerre de
civilisation
est ce que veut d'âge c'est que tout le
monde pense que eux ils détiennent la
vérité sur l'islam
pardon je peux dire un mot juste pour
l'intérêt ce que je trouve de fascinant
ce que vous dites c'est que on revient
les pieds sur terre on voit se
construire l'abrutissement c'est donc
pas quelque chose qui a été donné en
même temps que le texte autrement dit il
suffit pas d'être en contact avec islam
pour devenir un dingue alors vous
travaillez sur la prévention et sur le
désordre événement il ya quand même 700
familles qui ont fait appel à vous entre
janvier 2014 et octobre 2015 ça montre
l'ampleur du drame jeudi à 1 on suit 700
jeunes
700 jeunes qui tous ont pratiquement été
pris à la frontière menotté qui ont des
fois essayé de partir deux fois trois
fois quatre fois à l'âge de 13 ou 14 ans
et certains rares qui se sont échappés
et qu'ils sont pas en détention et pour
le moment je touche du bois ils sont
stabilisés au sens où 1 ils sont pas
passés à l'action en france 2 ils ont
arrêté de vouloir partir et 3 ils
essayent de sortir de cette idéologie
alors vous intéresser beaucoup aux
filles c'est le plus étonnant
effectivement paraître dahmane donc elle
est parti là bas c'est la survivante and
voilà mais quand on quand elle arrive on
lanvern dans le mât car c'est quoi le
maca quand les filles arrivent en série
en fait elles sont pas le droit de
marcher si elles ne sont pas mariés donc
elles sont fermées dans une énorme
maison fermée et on apprend tellement
pas de matelas chacune qu'elles n'ont
pas d'eau pas de nourriture pas de
corans non plus d'ailleurs au passage
elle n'en sortirons qu'à condition
qu'elle puisse se marier avec celui qui
va venir les demandeurs et donc elles
vont accepter de se marier avec des
inconnus fort d'une douche pour manger
quelque chose et donc annan est la seule
rescapée vivante qui a pu s'échapper de
dèche ll n'y allez pas du tout pour
combattre elle pensait que c'est un
monde où il y aurait un vrai amour une
vraie solidarité des vrais soeur pas
d'injustice pas de voleur c'était ça
c'était ce que j'appelle d'iceland elle
en sourit maintenant elle dit maintenant
sourit mais vous dites quand même
qu'elle a une certaine nostalgie et
qu'elle ressent de la culpabilité
ne pas avoir été une bonne musulmane
brigitte quand même c'est bien le
rappeler ça parce que j'ai écrit le
livre ya deux mois et c'est vrai qu'il
ya deux mois est là elle se disait qu
est-ce que comme une femme battue est ce
que finalement j'ai pas été à la hauteur
pour pas voir que finalement c'était pas
super un super projet mais maintenant
vous voyez deux mois plus tard c'est
terminé vous êtes un travail remarquable
c'est gentil
[Applaudissements]
bon alors jean-luc mélenchon
pendant longtemps la gauche a refusé de
s'attaquer au problème de la
radicalisation pour pas paraître
islamophobe je conteste le terme
d'islamophobie quoique je le comprenne
je comprends ce qu'on veut dire ce sont
les musulmans qui pensent qu'on leur en
veut parce qu'ils sont musulmans donc je
comprends l'homme mais moi je défends
l'idée qu' on a le droit de ne pas aimer
l'islam on a le droit de ne pas aimer la
religion catholique et que ça fait
partie de nos libertés et par conséquent
je n'ai jamais accepté ce terme même si
je le comprends et que je partage l'idée
qu'aujourd'hui les musulmans sont mis
dans le sale rôle comme il y a une
génération c'était les juifs et que des
milliers de gens souffrent en silence
parce qu'ils n'ont rien à voir avec tout
ça joe fois le jeu il ya un truc qui me
dérange dans vos deux discours c'est que
vous faites en sorte l'un et l'autre
d'expliquer qu' il n'y a aucun rapport
dans les attentats avec l'islam or vu
passer complètement à côté selon moi du
problème numéro un aujourd'hui qui se
posent à nous en france pas à l'étranger
en france c'est qu'est ce qu'on va faire
avec les musulmans demain en france il
ya aujourd'hui un islamisme un islam
radical qui se développe à vitesse grand
v dans notre pays dans des endroits on
sait très bien lesquels d'ailleurs dans
les banlieues notamment et que tous ces
gens qu'on va faire des attentats
aujourd'hui sont des gens qui ont qui se
sont formés dans des mosquées bondées
cave etc et ne pas le dire ne pas dire
que ça a un rapport avec l'islam ça fait
qu'on ferme va fermer les yeux comme on
l'a fait après charlie et on ne réglera
pas le problème il ya juste un souci
dans votre raisonnement c'est que
qu'est-ce que vous faites du fait que
50% des jeunes qui sont embrigadés n'ont
rien à voir avec l'islam n'ont jamais
connu d'immigration mais le sort des
gens de famille athée ou catholique
premièrement je pense envers les femmes
et les jeunes qui sont signalés non pas
des jeunes qui sont embrigadés non mais
je ne reviendrais gagner qui sont par
trois différences à la frontière ça fait
d'en parler des jeunes dont aux dons
dont vous avez reçu des signalements ça
n'a rien à voir avec les jeunes
absolument pas il ya 4000 parents qui
ont signalé leurs enfants d'accord c'est
ce dont vous parlez sont 4000 sont pas
700 les 700 que j'ai moi c'est des
jeunes qui ont été menottés à la
frontière qu'on a récupéré bien qu'ils
se sont enfuis d'âge c'est pas des gens
signalé c'est des gens embrigader s'est
exercé des gens qui devaient passer à
l'acte c'est vous parle de cela
ces 700 là j'ai 60 % qui sont de famille
athée qui sont juifs et qui sont
catholiques mission s'il y en a que 3 %
c'est encore plus donc comment comment
expliquez vous que des gens qui ne
connaissent pas l'islam d'accord qui
n'est pas eu d'instruction que les 30%
de référence musulmane ce soit toutes
les familles qui ne pratiquent pas
l'islam les familles qui connaissent
l'islam elle se protéger de neige vous
savez pourquoi parce que nous on sait ce
que c'est l'islam donc on vous croit ni
vous ni d'âge parce que vous et dash
vous avez la même définition de l'islam
vous pensez que c'est une religion par
essence archaïque qui par essence va
faire couper des têtes nous nous savons
que ce n'est pas le produit de notre
religion bien on continue donc avec la
lutte contre des il ya le terrain
d'abord 22 pays participent à la
coalition mais 95% des bombardements
sont réalisés enfin jusqu'à dernièrement
par les américains la france va lancer
quelques bombinettes de temps en temps
les russes taper sur les haines ligue
bachar al assad aujourd'hui est ce qu'on
peut penser arriver un seul front bas
c'est en train de se faire puisque
finalement landes va rencontrer poutine
et que pour l'instant il semble qu'il
ait une coordination des bombardements
qui n'existait pas il ya trois jours il
ya un moment où face à la catastrophe
qui est en train d'avancer
les les fantaisies régional qui était
fondamentalement différentes sont en
train de se coaliser pour c'est ce que
jean luc mélenchon appelle l'heureuse
volte face de françois hollande elle est
heureuse mais elle est extrêmement
tardive non moi je vais vous dire un
truc dans cette émission ça fait trois
ans qu'on dit qu'il faut arrêter de
considérer poutine comme un ennemi et
que s'il faut s'associer avec bachar al
assad pour flinguer d'âge tant pis on
sait bien associer avec staline pour
flinguer clair les trois ans compte vie
ça veut dire que ça fait trois ans que
poutine a raison sur tout et françois
hollande a tort on est en train de
donner raison au type qui était présente
et je crois que je crois qu hillary
clinton la vitre il avait comparé à un
nazi quasiment bruit et aujourd'hui on
entend dire là ce type à raison depuis
le début c'est comme moi j'ai reçu des
mails j'ai reçu des coups de téléphone
en me disant arrête de soutenir poutine
je ne soutenait pas abouti je voulais
juste qu'on s'associe avec lui les
russes sont nécessairement nos
partenaires voilà il faut que chaque
français comprennent ça mais jean-luc
depuis sarkozy qui a rejoint l'otan nous
sommes devenus les parfaits caniche des
américains mais parce qu'il ya un point
de vue complètement idiot logique de
ceux qui dirigent aujourd'hui le parti
socialiste était d'une manière tout à
fait c'est nouveau dans la dc cointe
matériaux logis qui nous interdit de
nous allier avec poutine contre d'âge
qui nous interdit de reconnaître que
bachar el-assad est pour le moment pour
le moment un allié qui nous interdit de
signer la paix avec l'iran alors que
même les américains font la paix avec
l'iran et on a tout intérêt est trompé
avec l'iran
qu'est-ce-qui comment vous appelez cette
idéologie qu il défendu hollande valls
effet on apprend au premier niveau c'est
à dire ce que c'est concrètement
concrètement ces de l'atlantisme ces
gens considèrent que ce que les
américains trouvent bon est bon pour
tout le monde voilà voilà ensuite vous
avez un deuxième niveau c'est que y
compris par rapport à ce que racontent
les nord-américains et choisissent
dedans et ils sont plus proche des
néoconservateurs qui sont des
va-t-en-guerre que des démocrates qui
sont plus plus modérée geoffroy en fait
j'étais d'accord je suis assez d'accord
avec lui mais où l'on sait depuis québec
avec moi je ne sais pas il ya un truc
par contre sur l'idéologie qui est
encore pire on n'en a pas parlé c'est
par rapport à la série puisque c'est
quand même que cette semaine bernard
squarcini l'ancien patron des
renseignements révèle qu' il ya deux ans
la syrie lui a proposé de lui donner les
noms des des jihadistes français qui
étaient allés en syrie et que manuel
valls à l'époque ministre de l'intérieur
a refusé de la voir parce que ça voulait
dire coopérer avec les scieries ce qui
vous avez raison pour des motifs
idéologiques est interdit à l'heure où
aujourd'hui on se remet à travailler
avec la syrie pour manuel valls c'est
juste c'est gravissime comme comme acte
alors on continue avec les lois
sécuritaires alors jean-luc moi je vous
dis tout de suite et assez
tranquillement je ne suis pas convaincu
par la proclamation de l'état d'urgence
sur trois mois cette voie parce que ça
apporte de plus l'intervention en salle
samedi a été réglée par des moyens
ordinaires ce qu'il dit est
partiellement faux puisque c'est pas
pour être désagréable mais ceux ci se
sont affranchis de toute décision de
justice puisque même les maires le maire
de saint-denis personne n'a été prévenu
à la veille à 4h30 du matin donc c'est
une chose qui a été décidé par la
direction générale de la police qui a
envoyé le rêve et la berri sans prévenir
personne donc on est dans un état
d'urgence de fait qu'il faut prolonger
parce qu'aucun état d'urgence prolongé à
trois mois c'est plus un état d'urgence
et un état commun et vous créez un
revers de la main etc etc le jeu vous
vous arrêtez l'état d'urgence va vous
envoyer un signal extrêmement négatif
bien alors assignation à résidence bonne
idée mauvaise idée boni bonne idée mais
mais ça pourrait aller beaucoup plus
loin moi je trouve que l'idée de laurent
wauquiez de les interner faire de la
rétention adminstrative ces gens là sont
dangereux sont une menace pour notre
sécurité il faut l'événement vise à
lever vous il faut les juger d'abord
mais non le problème c'est que c'est
justement on fait la guerre on fait pas
la guerre c'est si on fait la guerre à
ces gens là à moi ils menacent la
sécurité je préfère les savoir retarder
si vous me dites je prenais un criminel
qui va jeter une bombe voulez-vous
l'interné je vous réponds oui mais deux
secondes après monsieur dit ah bon les
internés tous y en a quatre mille donc
vous savez comme moi que si on a
interdit car si personne ou ça s'appelle
un camp où on leur met un bracelet et il
faut avoir le personnel pour surveiller
tout le monde que nous n'avons pas
visite on n'a pas les moyens qu'est ce
qu'on attendait mais thierry commençons
par tirer les leçons avant de passer
encore comme d'habitude vite vite
concrètement big man 2 secondes comment
nous allons régler la guerre mondiale
thierry comment en est on arrivé là une
suite d'erreurs qu'il faut corriger il
faut restaurer l'état dans sa force en
france il faut restaurer que
géopolitique qui tiennent debout il faut
donc arrêter la guerre là où elle part
comme je le dis et le répète ça ça peut
être réglée en même pas deux mois dounia
il ya quelque chose de très simple
qu'apparemment vaud s'est pas pris en
compte c'est que les 4000 personnes qui
sont signalés sur les 4000 personnes
c'est 3800 parents qui ont téléphoné à
la police pour dire mon enfant est en
train de se faire embrigader
si ils nous écoutent aujourd'hui je peux
vous assurer d'une chose il ya plus un
seul parent qui va signaler que son
enfant est embrigadé par ce que vous
avez dit on va tous les internés
d'emblée dès qu'ils sont signalés alors
là maintenant vous êtes en train de tout
casser le système de prévention que le
gouvernement a mis en place depuis deux
ans et c'est pour ça que les gens
appellent et c'est pour ça qu'à 4000
personnes qui sont fâchés monsieur
dernière question faut-il fermer les
mosquées intégristes et expulser les
prédicateurs salafistes parce qu'en
angleterre par exemple il en expulse e10
par semaine et quand un prédicateur fait
un prêche dans une mosquée il doit la
faire accepter par une autorité
musulmane locale en france les mecs
raconte n'importe quoi où ils veulent
est-ce qu'il faut fermer les mosquées
intégristes à ma connaissance ce
nettoyage il a déjà été fait ah bon oui
à ma connaissance en tout cas tous les
musulmans savent qui a toujours eu des
micros dans les mosquées tous les
musulmans savent que le radicalisme
autour des mosquées parce que justement
il se méfie énormément de la police
française et à ma connaissance il ya
très peu de jeunes qui se font
embrigader à l'intérieur de la mosquée
et au contraire ils font bien attention
d'aller à l'extérieur ça c'est ma
connaissance le nuage voulait ce que le
mot de la fin die jeudi nous gagnerons
parce que nous aimons la mort plus que
vous n'aimez la vie et le mot de la fin
c'est que il faut pas tomber dans leur
piège l'islam c'est pas la mort l'hélice
là même la fin du monde dans l'islam
c'est symbolisé par un arbre qui renaît
alors ne tombons pas dans leur piège et
donnons-nous la main pour dire que la
vie c'est plus fort que la mort
voilà jean luc mélenchon même s'il
aimerait bien avec nous je crois le
jeune verger et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu